aún no ya se está quedando obsoleta
debería realmente dar una modificación
contundente dentro de la ONU para que en
efecto se terminen de resolver estos
conflictos porque pues se se reúnen
digamos se pronuncia sobre conflictos
internacionales Pero al final no termina
pasando nunca nada Mira la guerra en
Ucrania ya llevamos más de seis meses y
todo está igual Más allá de una
pronunciación que hace la ONU o
cualquier otro país pues nadie toma como
acciones concretas O mejor dicho Rusia
pues no hace caso lo que dice la ONU Sí
a ver el poder coercitivo de la ONU ya
se ha demostrado y básicamente el
Consejo de Seguridad que es limitado es
prácticamente muchos sentidos nulo y yo
creo que este mensaje de ampliar que
está basado en la lógica que muchas
veces los conflictos están generados por
algunos de los que está sentado entonces
con seguridad Entonces es muy difícil
que sucedan cosas en estas condiciones
el mundo ha cambiado la estructura
geopolítica cambió la ONU no ha cambiado
muy poco entonces creo que es momento de
cambiar y que participe en países que
también tienen otra Visión lo que son
los conflictos hoy el consejo de
seguridad de la ONU que son los que
muchas veces tienen que definir que se
hacen muchas veces son los que
participan en ese conflicto entonces
Cómo podemos pretender que tomen alguna
decisión que tenga sentido y que tenga
efecto cuando están sentados en el mismo
lugar están del lado de los dos lados
del mostrador no este Entonces eso es
muy difícil y también habló de una
resolución diplomática ante ante este
conflicto Qué tan lejos estamos digamos
que nuevamente las partes se sienten en
la mesa con estos ánimos tan crispados y
tan caldeados estos últimos días entre
entre Ucrania y Rusia eso también puede
ser una utopía digamos de alguna manera
o a lo mejor en el corto plazo por parte
del presidente Joe biden que está guerra
termine en una manera justa
a ver yo creo que la salida va a ser de
hecho y es un poco lo que te comentaba
anteriormente Y esto se está
configurando para para el
posicionamiento de Rusia en el sureste y
y y anexando esas partes de Ucrania
cuatro o cinco lugares en los cuales va
a ser referéndum Que obviamente por la
lógica de cómo está estructurado
seguramente va a tener los votos
positivos este sería extraño que
perdiera ahí y eso lo veo muy difícil
que pase el ámbito de la negociación yo
creo que eso se va a terminar dando por
hecho y que lamentablemente Ucrania va
va a resignar esa parte de su territorio
no no veo otra opción y y no creo que
sean una negociación diplomática por lo
menos por ahora claro Gonzalo también
otro punto muy importante que tocó el
presidente Joe biden y es en relación a
las tensiones que sean también ayudado
en estas últimas semanas entre Estados
Unidos y china en torno a la lista de
Taiwán Estados Unidos dijo que no quería
un conflicto que no quería una guerra
fría que quería que los países si
tuvieran alianzas digamos libres pero
que no tuvieran ninguna responsabilidad
política no De estar de un lado o del
otro esto también Pues digamos tras la
visita de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi a Taiwán y
dijo una frase muy importante que me
gustaría que pues un poco dijo que no
quería que un cambio status quo con
China y que estaba de acuerdo digamos
con la política de una sola china pero
ahí hay una contradicción entre lo que
dice presidente yobidy y lo que hace
Estados Unidos no al tener también
relaciones comerciales con Taiwán y
apoyarlo de alguna manera políticamente
no
bueno acá creo que dijiste la palabra
clave no yo creo que hay hay una visión
quizás muy antigua es imposible pensar
en que en en en el estatus quo con
Taiwán cuando uno está diciendo que
quiere una sola china creo que ahí hay
una contradicción enorme y que es parte
de tratar de estar bien con las dos
posiciones y eso no es viable en la
política internacional es muy difícil
estar bien con las dos posiciones y acá
también hay que tomar otro tema en
cuenta no también Estados Unidos
Próximamente va a tener elecciones y y
ahí va a depender de Qué signo termina
liderando nuevamente Estados Unidos para
ver cómo esta posición se refuerza se
debilita o se cambia totalmente no este
yo creo que de eso va a depender mucho
el gobierno demócrata ha tratado de
ponerle paño frío pero no creo que sea
la solución tratar de quedar bien con
los dos porque va a ser muy difícil es
muy difícil pararse claro y quedar bien
con los dos en medio oriente hay dos
puntos importantes Gonzalo ya para ir
finalizando nuestra conversación porque
la simplemente se me acaba el tiempo
para tantas cosas que que podríamos
analizar en nuestra conversación pero
bueno primero vamos con con nuevamente
el llamado a dos estados en el conflicto
entre Israel y Palestina por parte del
presidente
joeyden realmente es posible que esto se
logre como se podría lograr esto de dos
estados
bueno eso también es un poco muy similar
a lo que estamos hablando con lo de
China y Taiwán Yo creo que es muy
voluntarista Lamentablemente mucho de lo
que escuchamos también de del acuerdo de
biden eh Perdón del discurso de vader va
mucho a un acuerdo de buena voluntad lo
cual hemos visto que eso nos ha pasado
en las últimas décadas y que es muy
difícil que eso suceda por lo menos en
el corto plazo y el conflicto sigue va a
seguir y va a ser muy difícil por lo
menos ver el corto plazo el
funcionamiento de dos estados
independientemente de que uno lo diga en
un discurso muchas veces eso lo tiene
que bajar a tierra y yo creo que eso hoy
no está bajado a tierra y no están las
condiciones para eso sin duda también
hablemos o Gonzalo de Irán no el acuerdo
nuclear con este país ganó proliferación
de armas nucleares también habló el
presidente Racing antes de que hablara
del presidente Joe biden y pues acusó de
alguna manera Estados Unidos y decir que
fue administración del antecesor de Jovi
dentro Donald Trump que pisoteó el
acuerdo nuclear de 2015 cuando se retiró
unilateralmente qué va a pasar con este
acuerdo nuclear realmente sí se va
digamos a salvar este pacto que hicieron
estas naciones en el año 2015
el pacto se ha retomado muchísimas veces
este y muchas veces irán a incumplido lo
mismo ha pasado con Corea del Norte Como
también comentaba el presidente de vaiga
Entonces es muy difícil nosotros acá en
Latinoamérica También tenemos las
experiencias regionales de lo que fueron
los atentados en Argentina no en los
cuales también el gobierno de Irán este
por lo menos Las investigaciones apuntan
hacia el gobierno de Irán entonces y el
gobierno obviamente trata de desligarse
es muy difícil este creer en su posición
no hoy uno recibe la información de que
van hacia un lado y que van a colaborar
y después cuando el proceso avanza la
colaboración se corta no Irán sabe que
es un instrumento importante para su
defensa avanzar en los